so why are you not resigning
why are you not going to resign Mr
swarbrick on Friday morning Gareth
swarbrick was adamant he'd remained the
chief executive of Rochdale Borough wide
housing not even 48 hours later and a
board that supported him have now sacked
him
in a statement the Housing Association
said the board has taken the decision to
remove Gareth swarbrick from his post as
chief executive of rbh with immediate
effect we will now work to appoint an
external interim chief executive our
original instincts were for Gareth to
stay on to see the organization through
this difficult period and to make the
necessary changes but we all recognize
that this is no longer tenable nothing's
going to bring him back the news came as
hundreds gathered in Rochdale Town
Center to pay tribute to a wabashack a
two-year-old boy who died from the
prolonged exposure to mold and damp in
his family home it was the inadequate
accommodation and failure of rbh which
led to his death the family were deeply
saddened that following this inquest rbh
did nothing that expressed their
confidence in their chief executive
despite in the courtroom doing
everything to indicate that significant
changes would be made
the fact that rbh's chief executive had
to be sacked as opposed to resign for
the family speaks volumes
however they find it wholly unacceptable
that the board expressed confidence in
him in the first place
the family still feel that much more
needs to be done
and it was a decision welcomed by
Rochdale Council who are now calling for
full ownership of rbh
I think it's been chaotic from the start
chopping and changing and first of all
um completely stonewalling on the issue
saying you know oh Mr swarbrick has to
stay and then suddenly after all this
pressure has been put on them they do a
complete turnaround to sack him as they
have done it's not chaotic from their
points of view getting rid of the man
who ultimately holds responsibility for
rbh might be welcomed by many but the
death of a wab ishak has raised a number
of claims of wider failings in an
organization designed to protect and to
support people in need the culture was
horrible it was bullying toxic the
amount of people I know who left the
organization were in tears for six years
Dave not his real name worked at rbh
before resigning he asked us to protect
his identity as he spoke of his
experience at the Housing Association
the total disregard for the tenants and
the cost cutting was completely obvious
and it's really sad to be honest I've
seen tenants suffering because of this
culture
awab's family felt discriminated against
because of they say what they look like
and where they're from Rochdale Bureau
housing we have a message for you
stop discriminating stop being racist
stop providing unfair treatment to
people coming from abroad to a refugees
or Asylum Seekers an allegation Dave
agrees with is rbh a racist organization
in your view in my view yeah yeah I
think it's sad to say but it is rbh
accept assumptions were wrongly made in
awab's case but said they were not a
racist organization they told us their
culture is one of collaboration and
mutuality Dave also believes there's
only one way to avoid another tragedy do
you think any more people could die at
the hands of rbh's properties I
definitely think there'll be more deaths
due to lack of repairs the only way that
tenants will be safe is if rbh is closed
down and the council takes it back over
we may never know exactly what went on
inside rbh in the days and weeks leading
up to awab's death but it's clear that
for all the unanswered questions it's
more than just the office culture that's
in need of repair
into man Rashid Sky News Rochdale